wait hold on how young of a baby do you
have he's
almost 11 months i had like a secret
covered baby
that's jessica beale opening up about
her and justin timberlake's second son
it's just the most spectacular thing in
january e.t confirmed the power couple
had welcomed their second child in july
now 11 month year old phineas who became
a younger brother to their firstborn
six-year-old silas this was such a big
change because it had been six years
six years since we did all that stuff
so you must have had your baby what like
month
four of quarantine i had him in the
summer so yeah like
halfway through or i guess whatever and
on the most recent episode of doc
shepard's podcast
armchair expert the actress revealed she
didn't originally plan to keep her
pregnancy and birth a secret
i had like a secret covered baby what oh
my god congratulations
it wasn't like it's supposed to be a
secret it was just cove it happened and
then
i went to montana with my family and
never left
since coveted restrictions were in a
constant state of flux throughout the
pandemic
jessica said there were concerns that
justin wouldn't be allowed in the room
for phineas's birth
the hospital restrictions had just
changed
and there was a moment there that there
was no
buddy allowed at all yeah and i was
really getting nervous about
that situation but yes he was allowed
i think if i had to be there alone that
would have been horrible
i would have been really scared now with
a family of four
jessica admitted there have been
challenges but said overall their lives
have been amazing
the balance of everything is is very
different
and super hard but i agree i mean it's
amazing it's so interesting it's so
funny
the conversations i'm having now with my
six year old
is so cool like he's a real person yeah
saying the funniest stuff and he's so
sensitive and tender and
it's just so interesting to see that
part of it happen
and the little one is just cute as hell
jessica also reacted to dax asking if
their kids might one day
enter the family business my knee-jerk
reaction is oh god no please no
but then i look at these kids and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
they're probably going to be musical not
let them play the piano
or not let them take a voice lesson if
that's their passion i don't want to be
that parent to stifle a dream but
man if my kid would just be like let's
go learn about corn in iowa
back in january justin's former nsync
bandmate lance bass
gushed to et about baby phineas jessica
and justin reportedly
welcomed their second child have you had
a chance to say
congratulations at all
well of course yeah we i've talked very
you know several times and of course
uh we knew it before anyone else did so
yeah
it's been a fun celebration and they're
they're very very happy
what was the last thing that you guys
talked about in the instinct
group chat obviously it's not touring or
doing anything no new music
uh no it's all it's all about babies you
know it's all about the new one that
they just brought in so uh yeah it's all
been conversations about a newborn
is is the baby so cute do you know the
name
uh i can i'm not gonna tell that name
good question but there's no way he
would he would kill me
all right but the baby's cute of course
i'm gonna look it's justin and jess's
baby of course it is